[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
So now we're in the
Android Wear area.
And we're going to
take a look at some
of the newest watches
with the design lead
from Android Wear, Bret.
Hi, Brett.
How you doing?
BRETT: Hi, Timothy.
Doing great.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So, I was
talking to David Singleton
earlier today.
And he said, you have to
check out the new TAG watch.
Can you show it to me?
BRETT: Yeah.
Yeah, I can.
So, here it is.
And you can also see that
it's available in, you know,
this diamond studded
edition, as well.
And one of the things that's
really nice about the TAG
Connected is that it's modular.
And that's actually in the name.
And so, not only can
you swap bands, but
you can also swap out the tabs
on the device, in addition to
the bands.
So you could have like
a metal bracelet band,
a leather band, a sport
band, as well as you
can change these
accents out as well.
So, they can be-- you can go for
same tone, or contrasting tone.
And that all snaps
back together.
And when it's together,
it's like rock solid.
So that's one example of
how partners are really
doing really interesting things
on the hardware side with,
of course TAG, it's got
all its iconic watch faces
in the software.
And it's all powered by
the Android Wear platform.
Yeah, so that's pretty exciting.
It was fun to be in Switzerland
for the launch event for this,
too.
They know how to host.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I bet they do.
Tell me one other
thing I want to know
is, for developers, what's the
new thing that they get to do
that you're most excited about?
BRETT: Really, I'm going
to demo a different watch
at that point.
So the best thing that
developers can do now
is they can start powering
the complication slots,
or developing watch
bases that show off
really actionable, in great,
great information for end
users.
So here, I've got this watch
face that ustwo developed,
and it's got four slots,
in addition to the time.
So, all I have to do
is long press on it.
Just, awesomely, it's
working just like it should.
So I long press on it, and I
can change any of these slots.
So I can make my next meeting.
I can go and do a countdown to
some important upcoming date.
I can show today's date.
I can go and for, let's see,
let's change the layout,
you know, over to
different ones.
I can have more slots.
And now, I can do stuff like
put a fitness goal that I've
set up, you know,
right on my watch face
with just a few taps.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Whoa.
Cool.
BRETT: And so developers
can do two things.
They can either be
the watch face itself.
If you're a
developer, or you feel
like you've got a really
strong sense of style,
you can develop a watch face.
But you don't necessarily have
to be an expert in, you know,
what data does the user want.
You can just let
the users decide.
You can add these slots
for complications,
and let data providers,
either from the system,
or from other apps, power them.
And the benefit to users
is that they'll really
like your watch face.
Or if the users
are already using
something like
Robinhood for stocks,
or Google Fit for
fitness tracking,
they can get that data
right on their watch face.
So, we're really
excited about what
developers are doing there.
And what-- there's still a lot
of possibility left to mine.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thanks so much, Brett.
BRETT: Sure thing, Timothy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]